[Music]
yeah so round running episode 26 you
know and we're doing it right now
this is congratulations now I you know I
don't know man sometimes you're gonna
start [ __ ] just chillin like it's a
conversation sometimes gonna start out
with a bang sometimes you're gonna just
start out and it's gonna start out slow
so who's gonna start out you know I mean
this is how it's gonna go we're in white
shoes pissed off how dirty they are
that's cool dude when you wear white
shoes you try to keep them clean doesn't
happen bothers me but guys listen so I
got it we got to start off this episode
by saying we got new merch on the
podcast on the on the for the podcast
and it's on my website crystally accom
click around hit store on that front
page and you could represent the podcast
but man these these shirts are selling
like we've sold a lot of these shirts
and they're gonna be gone so get out
there and get your [ __ ]
congratulations t-shirt or your shirt
with that congratulations artwork or the
[ __ ] coveted free conch shirt with
the American flag very cool you don't
get these Kudus but we're also start
getting some new designs and some new
shirts coming up soon so check that out
and let me read off some dates where I'm
gonna be soon before yeah before we get
in to this episode full force full
throttle we're less echoey too because
we got more [ __ ] what do you call
them you know what I'm talking about
more of those great things those
soundproof things so here is where I'm
gonna be coming up
that's gone oh oh okay well so let me
tell my producer the Austin one you
didn't get rid of in the Albuquerque
when you didn't get rid of now we know
what that means one fire one fire him
but because he didn't do it right but
Montreal is coming up on like Thursday
and Nashville we're gonna do the weekend
there and also adding shows I believe
Hollywood California I'm doing August
19th at the improv on Melrose two shows
Salt Lake City Utah come out and see me
Mormons you [ __ ] the but come out and
see me
you're virgin but you still [ __ ] the
bot come out and see me
sounds pretty predatorial but it's not
I'm just I heard that Mormons you know
sometimes I'd like to stay virgins but
still [ __ ] in the butt Phoenix Arizona
pretty cool Tempe Arizona it's gonna be
too ha New Brunswick New Jersey for some
reason I'm gonna be there I'm from New
Jersey so come on out Spokane Washington
why am I gonna be there you live there
who are ya Charlotte North Carolina
Irvine California Melbourne Australia in
Sydney Australia and possibly other
dates in in Australia so that's what is
up go get your shirts go get the tickets
on my website and that's what's up I
don't know let's see so I been chillin
I've been in LA let's see I've been in
LA because I was in
well actually I'm excited to go do let's
talk about this I'm excited to go do the
Montreal Just for Laughs festival I'm
into my own show on Thursday every
comedian loves going it's the biggest
Comedy Festival in the world and it's my
it's great every comedian is like so
[ __ ] happy and so excited to get
there and hang out with the other
comedian
but I think I'm I love the festival but
I think I am the guy who everyone's like
let's [ __ ] go we're gonna do it we're
Cudas and I'm like all right yeah let's
go and then I get there and it's just
like everybody's there that we see in LA
anyway so and then also like people are
like you want to hop on different shows
do it come on let's hop on the show you
want to be and get there in the guy with
the laminate is like you want to do is
you want to get on the show it's Hudson
and friends over the [ __ ] it's called
you know I don't know it is but and
you're like what is it where is it and
they're like I it's a 15-minute ride
away and you didn't do six minutes I
don't want to do that because I don't
want to drive so far to do a six minute
set ferry AAB it's very odd because I'm
gonna do an hour on Thursday I'm gonna
do a TV Cape taping for Canada
even though but you do these TV tapings
for Canada nobody sees it less people
see it then when you do when you do it
live who's what's what's Canadian TV
what's Canadian TV what do you have what
are you watching I feel like it's just
prank shows and Fraser
hey Canadian TV it's prank shows with
loud laugh tracks outside prank shows
where somebody like stands up with a big
cellphone and it is like and then it's
like and then it goes ha ha ha ha ha
Canada that's how they say it cuz French
[ __ ] not I mean to be I don't mean to be
prejudiced but French is [ __ ] I like to
play a game when I go to Montreal is
who's the most French guy dude and it's
so funny to look at people's faces and
think that that guy's the most French
guy in the world because also sometimes
they are sometimes they're not but when
I look at them they turn French in my
foot in my mind like a French guy looks
a little bit different than a white guy
it's like the difference between well
what a white racist would say between a
Korean and a Japanese person because you
can't tell deaf can't tell deaf
cuz you know Japanese people are way
more Japanese looking you know but mmm
yes I'm gonna do the festival and chill
out for about three days tried to his
least amount of shows as I possibly can
Canada is just cool as a whole I can
always tell when somebody's from Canada
though I can always tell when somebody's
from Toronto - specifically people love
to talk about poutine you get there and
they're like hey did you try the poutine
hey you know what it is fries and gravy
try them both could imagine how it could
imagine how it tastes
hey have you tried poutine oh no oh
you're missing out what is it fries and
gravy ah I can imagine that no why
eating gravy so many times and eating
fries millions of times I eat fries eda
eat gravy smart so let me ask a question
why do I have to goddamn try it you know
it's like wearing pants all the time or
a shirt all the time and people like
dude you ever put on all the outfit Oh
what is it are you putting on a [ __ ]
shirt and pants at the same time command
that's an outfit I feel it do it I can
taste it and I've had poutine guess what
it tastes like fries gravy this what it
tastes like fries grave poutine also is
one of those things that looks like
diarrhea even before you ate it hey is
it going in my mouth is coming out
Masshole I can't tell either way it goes
in comes out same way know why this is
brown and it's messy it's got cheese on
it [ __ ] now people are gonna tweet me
and be like no there's different ways to
eat poutine now that's interesting hey
eff [ __ ] yeah
this is the others oh really it [ __ ]
yeah people be like nah I can get cheese
on it you can get [ __ ] different
cheeses you get [ __ ] you know
different [ __ ] things on it what can
you put on poutine poutine
we got the Apple TV setup and now my I'm
trying to get them pretty sure to Google
what you can put on poutine
but you can put on heat 38 poutine
dishes that will knock your Canadian
socks off
hey that's literally is the most
Canadian headline of all time you don't
have to say Canadian on in it it's done
then you're being done then cheesy
lobster poutine yep
candy poutine bit cheeseburger poutine
with pickles bit shredded jerk chicken
poutine hey Blair for GWAR poutine
grilled cheese salad
hello sweet potato poutine sure that
ones the works okay that one looks
[ __ ] good though yoky poutine with
short rib ragout and gremolata what are
those words are just making up words now
Pooky poutine poochy to boot dude dude
oh dude have you tried Duty poutine
deep-fried poutine bites I love are the
OEC oh the notorious b.i.g poutine by
they say cuz if you don't know now you
know yeah but just [ __ ] you know chill
out with the poutine ice thinking
they're like the dumbest dishes you know
I'm not a foodie would never call myself
a foodie cuz good gunk
but best when people makes me mad how
much people think like but never would I
ever get soup soup is a drink okay hey
dude put it in a cup dude gazpacho it's
a cold drink oh dude you got the all
right so soup oh oh it's a [ __ ]
lobster bisque put in a cup oh it's hot
then guess what it is tea now let me ask
you a question
you got the nerve now let me ask a
question you got the nerve to make it
cold
do you have the nerve to make soup cold
and call it gazpacho hmm
it's a drink you know what I'll do with
it put in a cup I got an idea put it in
a sports bottle well drink it after I
work out gazpacho net drink dude soup
and there's always some guy that's like
no you'd be surprised you you know you
can fill up on soup oh yeah you got some
more belly you're not man you woman soup
is nothing put it in the cup drink it
that's your that's your liquid drink it
when you eat in the burger dude come on
man
soup man you know what we've evolved
past it they do just to make soup when
there was like candles that's how they
lit their place with candles and [ __ ]
now that we got electricity and you can
[ __ ] get chickens everywhere you
don't need to eat soup no why you know
in the [ __ ] 1600s I mean is a picture
of [ __ ] what having this no shut up
you know my producer is like he we are
Apple TV and he always second-guesses
everything and he's like it was this
gonna be distracting it's not gonna be
distracting because I'm a human and I
can just talk whenever I want to but he
put on a [ __ ] picture of Mark
Zuckerberg in a goddamn peanut butter
and jelly sandwich looks like he's
attacking it dude Mark Zuckerberg man is
a robot or what just lost my facebook
account but anyway yeah so don't eat
soup drink it put in a cop dude but you
with a spoon take the spoon put it down
on a napkin don't use it take the soup
pour it in the cup drink it because
you're drinking you know
when you're eating put it in a plate you
drink and drink it that's literally the
most congratulation [ __ ] you could
possibly say I I don't know by the way
here's something I want to talk about
and this is just a [ __ ] thing that
needs to be known now that technology is
advanced and [ __ ] like this if you ask
somebody for a location or like what's
the address or where you're going or
what's the person's number or what the
[ __ ] ever it is put it and you're
texting put it in a separate text field
okay if I say hey where are you and
somebody says oh I'm at this address and
then types the address in the same text
field
I got a do [ __ ] extra work I got it
copy and paste it and then put it in the
[ __ ] thing and then delete the part
where you [ __ ] said oh I'm at and
then I got a [ __ ] type copy and paste
this [ __ ] again and put it in the
[ __ ] maps and don't [ __ ] talk to
me like you could just click on the
thing and the things sometimes you can't
okay
sometimes you can't or when somebody
puts apartment B in it or some [ __ ]
oh yeah oh cool let me just click on it
cuz Google is gonna direct me where the
[ __ ] elevator is once I get out of my
car dude stop do you need to spread this
knowledge man now this is a first world
problem don't give [ __ ] in the first
world dude it drives me when people do
that [ __ ] oh it's the worst don't make
me do the extra work man you do it that
is
that is technologies advanced everybody
needs to know that cool sounds good
they say cool it sounds good text me
here no no no and then it make a
separate text field you guys are [ __ ]
kudus or do that man it's [ __ ] huge
Curtis by the way how long is Comic Con
I feel like it's [ __ ] three months I
feel like people are like doing a
comic-con and then I get [ __ ] on with
my life and I'm just living and [ __ ] and
then people are like at comic-con and
then I keep going and [ __ ] and people
are like oh it's the last day of
comic-con and I'm like it's [ __ ]
three months later how big is it how
long is it pretty long pretty soon it's
gonna get bigger and bigger dude when I
first went I was 12 or some [ __ ] and it
was a [ __ ] one Convention Center
thing and there was a like Gimli sign
and comics and and nobody was dressed up
like anything I mean there were like a
little bit of [ __ ] big-ass dorks
dress like the [ __ ] hey by the way if
you dress up like that you're a dork
okay and it's fine but that's what you
are and if you think you aren't I mean
wow you know you can do you can see a
little Pikachu ass down you can sit your
little [ __ ] guardians of the galaxy
oh yeah I do did you paint your whole
body blue you dork
are you part of the Blue Man Group no
you have superpowers No
thus you dork dude come on man
I saw the dorkiest [ __ ] video the
other day of Comic Con it was a woman
dressed up as Wonder Woman hey dork and
a guy was [ __ ] drawing her on an
etch-a-sketch hey a dork literally can't
look at that without coming hey is that
Wonder Woman and is he is he is that guy
drawing her on netiquette
oh I gotta go change my I gotta go
change my Jing COTH I mean dude drawing
her on an etch-a-sketch by the way the
etch-a-sketch was a mini at to sketch it
was so small and guess if that guy who
does the etch-a-sketch artwork jerks off
a lot
now I don't know he does but I know he
does
now do I know in a court of law could I
prove it no but if I had I was a lawyer
and I said and the case was and I
brought to the table well he does
and then I dropped a huge bomb and I be
like it's mini you are sentenced to
getting a bigger at your sketch and not
drawing [ __ ] Wonder Woman man I wrote
on the thing can't believe I don't know
who's the bigger dork than this thing
and you know it's like unbelievable
people will dress up as Drax Drax which
one's Drax the big blue one Google Drax
because I think Drax is the big [ __ ]
one Oh No maybe it's the [ __ ] uh yeah
I saw a guy dressed up as Drax from
guardians a galaxy of the galaxy said
that guardians of galaxy Suresh and dad
I saw a guy dressed as Rex guardians of
galaxy and I have four kids and dude he
was like a fat guy with like a [ __ ]
suit on he didn't do the paint he like
gotta got like skin-tight like a
stocking type [ __ ] and he was sad a
shape hey man you're not Drax you're
just some guy
saddest shape I mean this guy's so beefy
in real life Drax's I mean just look up
dracs cosplay hey man so fat I was so
fat some guys are just fat and is like I
love how [ __ ] Drax
I love how like that's Drax is probably
like the number one thing that a fat guy
goes to comic-con dresses up as you know
because you don't have you can kind of
cheat it right you can cheat it if
you're tall and lanky and [ __ ] you could
be spider-man but if you're just like
fat and you like look and you like don't
work out you'd be like I love comic-con
I'll just dress up as Drax I mean dude
you know that's the number one thing to
dress up as comic-con if you had a shape
as Drax do it you pear shape you're Drax
um it's just [ __ ] Drax is the guy
from guardians of galaxy I would like if
I had a kid I'd dress him up like the
Kraken like a four-year-old I'd make him
put a [ __ ] rag I'd have put a hair
all over we were like dad I don't want
to do that and I'd be like put on the
goddamn raccoon [ __ ] we're going to
comic-con
now get daddy's Drac stockings get
daddy's Drax stockings I'm 40 yeah I
mean comic-con is good
I love dorks no cuz I'm a dork - I do
[ __ ] like I'm a dork about standup
I mean I [ __ ] love stand-up it's like
everybody's a dork in Norway hopefully
you're a dork honestly if you're not
passionate about anything then you know
what the [ __ ] are you you're just some
guy that works at a cubicle I mean be
passionate if you're passionate about
YouTube you're passionate about YouTube
that's [ __ ] awesome if you're
passionate about [ __ ] Drax go get
those stockings I love it I'll make
funny all day long but I love it I'm
passionate about [ __ ] you're
passionate about you know you're
passionate about Game of Thrones great
if you're that mad that Ed Sheeran was
on Game of Thrones go jump off a
building
it's all entertainment y'all y'all
trying to sell [ __ ] Kleenex that's
what I'm trying to do trying to get
subscriptions whatever drives the
[ __ ] machine man and if you're mad
that ed Sheeran was on Game of Thrones
because it took you out of it hey man
you know what you should do when you're
watching Game of Thrones turn your head
to the side sometimes you'll see a couch
sometimes you see a fridge
sometimes you see tile sometimes you see
a poster that'll take out of it you know
why you're in a house or you're in a
[ __ ] apartment just look down you
know what you see your feet with Nikes
on or your [ __ ] socks
you know what they didn't have at Game
of Thrones Nikes you know what they
didn't have a game of Thrones your
[ __ ] huh man ass refrigerator you
know what they didn't have a [ __ ]
couch with with the [ __ ] nice like
floral pattern you're gonna get mad oh
dude
ed Sheeran come on dude Ed Sheeran's and
Game of Thrones
that takes me out of it turn your head
turn your head to the right what do you
see
don't get mad that ed Sheeran was on
Game of Thrones cuz look what's to your
right look down you have a deed asan
good hey walk outside look out the
window you'll see cars
it took me out of it ed sheeran was in
the [ __ ] by you CUDA get gunk that's
a [ __ ] combo dude dude if you're mad
cuz ed Sheeran was on the [ __ ] Game
of Thrones
by you CUDA get dunk I got a combo for
your ass by you killed a kid gunk that's
it man Orange Street Fighter you coot it
you CUDA you could it you could a bike a
dunk dunk dunk you could it you could
buy 342 for that ass
come on man [ __ ] mad cos ed sheeran
don't get mad at some other [ __ ] hey go
get mad at other things yeah mm-hmm
have you guys tried this wink winc I'm
not a drinker but it doesn't mean that I
don't like to have people over my house
and entertain and when my guests can
have great wine and I don't have to
worry about what I'm buying that makes
me happy because they're having a good
time now this company called wink they
give you access to exceptional wines
from all around the world and it's
awesome I've done it I have the wines at
my house people who drank them already
and they like them and they're great
go-to wink calm spelled you gotta go to
try it's called try wink calm spelled T
ry winc calm and you gotta go in there
you got to take a brief pallet profile
quiz and wink will recommend distinct
and interesting wines actually
customized to your palate okay it'll be
shipped directly to your door every
month it's so easy and it takes you
don't have to do the work it's just it's
it's really great trust me I do it none
of your time is wasting fitting in a run
to the store you'd have to do that
you're on your way home from work you
just go home from work
wait event you know you gotta go
sometimes to an event a be like oh we
got to stop and get why you're not to do
that anymore
wink bases the wines they send to you on
your taste preferences they'll also like
introduce you didn't like new wines and
rare wines and custom wines that are not
available anywhere else and they tell
you the story behind which each one so
it's kind of cool so now I act like I
know wine you know because a wink join
for free skip any month cancel anytime
and they have a 100% satisfaction
guarantee so you'll never pay for a
bottle you don't like right now wink is
offering listeners $20 off your first
order when you go to try wink comm /
Congrats
they'll even cover the cost of shipping
that's tri wink spelled T ry winc
calm / congrats and get $20 off your
first order now plus complimentary
shipping try wink calm / Congrats hi
guys have you tried naturebox
we all want to eat better but when it
comes to snacks sometimes it feels like
the whole world is delicious in a
billion calories versus boring and
tasteless right well it doesn't really
have to be that way upper game in the
snack department with nature box it has
over 100 snacks that taste good and are
actually better for you they're all made
from high-quality simple ingredients
which means no artificial colors flavors
or sweeteners so you can feel good about
what you're eating I eat all this stuff
I like to salt and vinegar veggie chips
because I like salt and vinegar and
their aged cheddar lentil oops
because love cheese and they got a nice
cheesy flavor and cheese taste now I'm
getting a hungry form right now you find
you definitely could find whatever you
like here at they're at nature box they
add new snacks every month inspired by
real customer feedback so if you say yes
or no on something then they'll put it
into the database in whatever but it's
great it's really simple you just go to
nature box calm and nature box will
deliver them right to your door and
there's really no risk if you ever try
snack you don't like then don't eat in H
nature box will replace it for free
right now you'll save even more nature
boxes offering fans three free snacks my
fans Congrats fans three free snacks
with your first order when you go to
nature box calm can grats that's nature
box calm
three snacks three free snacks in your
first order nature box calm
Congrats a nature box I'd like to feel
it when I do it you know so that's why I
go nature box yeah so
so [ __ ] sore dude I've been working
out really hard and I've been thinking
about it's so hard to eat it to work out
and also eat right because you want to
[ __ ] work out hard but then you want
to eat so much when you work after you
work out which is fine and I eat other
you're supposed to eat more if you're
gonna work out more but it's like you
want to eat you know I mean like I'm
addicted to all the sugar [ __ ] it's like
I'm supposed to not eat bread and just
keep working out I'm just eating salads
and then yeah I get I'm probably doing
it wrong
one faint but I crash and I eat these
[ __ ] burgers and [ __ ] and if I hear
one more time hey abs are made in the
kitchen yeah alright you know I don't
like that saying I don't like sayings
when people just get it get them on
board with the sayings abs are made in
the kitchen yeah alright I just imagine
envision people doing crunches on the
[ __ ] counter near the sink I just but
I eat burgers and [ __ ] you know and I
try not to eat I don't eat that much
meat I mean I eat some meat but late at
night it's [ __ ] hard what is it about
late at night just makes me want to put
all the food in my mouth in the daytime
I'm good I eat salads [ __ ] whatever
but abs are made in the kitchen man abs
are not made in the kitchen by the way
because if you don't work out you're not
gonna get abs if you just eat healthy
you may not get abs I don't know though
what the [ __ ] do I know I don't think
this is something I this is just a
thought I had this this week and this
literally has nothing to do with
anything but like if a girl has a blonde
boyfriend that's weird to me like if I
just like what happened there you missed
the the dark [ __ ] hair brown eyes
[ __ ] and you're just going out with a
guy you're just going to be going out
with a guy with blonde hair in it like
that just I know that that's not right
and I get people are attracted to
different things but when a girl is like
looks at a blonde dude and is like
that's the guy I got to make my man
that's such a trip to me dude
when [ __ ] cool ass dark haired dudes
are roaming around just like hey how's
it gone and then some [ __ ] guy with
blond hair is gonna steal your girl dude
if I was [ __ ] if I had my girl stolen
from me from a guy with blond hair I
don't know what I would do I don't know
what I would [ __ ] do like have it be
a brunette guy a [ __ ] bald guy any
kind of thing even a ginger but like a
blonde dude comes in and swoops her girl
up
like what the [ __ ] is the 80s come on
that's a weird man if you get your chick
swooped by a blonde dude I want to know
I want to know anybody out there if
you've heard if you if if you've been
had your girl ganked by a [ __ ] blonde
dude you must you got what you got like
no I got no passion you got no [ __ ]
humph what's up I'll never get my girl
taken from me by a [ __ ] blonde dude
I'm telling you right now bro blonde
dude blue eyed guy it's gonna come in
and take my girl [ __ ] out of here do it
now you got you got brown hair dude you
can come in and steal my girl all's fair
in love and war dude and I've been
[ __ ] you know I love to say all's fair
in love and war but if you're a [ __ ]
blonde dude named like Troy and you got
blue grayish eyes and you come in and
you steal my girl bro mmm committing
suicide how about a
dude with a with a [ __ ] this kills me
too if you're a blonde dude and you have
a [ __ ] leather jacket on and it's not
brown what are you doing you can't be a
blonde guy and get a [ __ ] black
leather jacket it just doesn't go right
if you're blonde you want a leather coat
you get it in brown man you get it in
brown that's my rule I know it makes no
[ __ ] sense but it just looks better
okay then you're at least like cool kind
of undercover cop vibe kind of guy but
if you're a blonde dude with a black
leather jacket you look like you're
dressed up for Halloween dye your hair
too baby
you pale as [ __ ] you can wear a dark
leather jacket as long as your hair is
dark as well you pale as [ __ ] you
blondie [ __ ]
you get dark get dark leather jacket
should do it you don't look good I think
I told you guys this but I used to try
this bit on stage where if you're fat
and you if you're fat and you try and
you buy a leather jacket like what are
you doing like work out first you know
what are you [ __ ] what do you like
slaying [ __ ] now hey you got [ __ ] 45
extra pounds and you went to Macy's and
bought a leather jacket you slain [ __ ]
now I mean I don't know unless you're
like [ __ ] fat mafia guy and you're
like running [ __ ] but if you're just
some guy with like a desk job and you
got 45 extra pounds and you bought a
leather jacket chewed on your blonde on
top of it what are you do I'm a Genoa
belong guy 45 pounds overweight wearing
a leather jacket what are you doing
and now everyone's know a lot of people
are gonna get mad at what I just said
but these are the thoughts I have these
are my confessions um no but these are
the thoughts I have and whatever I'm
just saying them out loud you know it's
a comedy podcast it doesn't work on
stage so I'm just kind of [ __ ]
throwing you the bits and pieces yeah
man it makes me laugh thinking of a
[ __ ] fat blond guy and a leather in a
dark leather jacket walking around all
cool and [ __ ] with like Kenneth Cole's
shoes on and [ __ ] baggy jeans bro if
you got a leather jacket on and baggy
jeans I switch it up switch it up
but comedian should never have to
apologize because that's why I wanted to
be one of the reasons why I wanted to be
a comedian is because I didn't want to
have to apologize I'm just [ __ ]
around anyway I mean we don't mean a
hundred percent of the [ __ ] we're saying
you know but I like when people tell me
that there's a problem with one of the
problems of being a comedian is people
come up to me or tweet me and they'll be
like [ __ ] you you ain't [ __ ] and then
I'll block them and then they'll hit me
with another account and be like why'd
you block me dude and I'd be like cuz
you said [ __ ] you or you ain't [ __ ] and
they're like I obviously was joking
you're a comedian you have that such you
should know oh I should know that you're
joking
because I'm the [ __ ] comedian I
should know that you're joking because
I'm the one that's funny hey man be
funnier
don't just say [ __ ] you it's not fun no
look it can be funny if a comedian says
[ __ ] you because you know he's a
comedian and you know you expected me to
be funny but [ __ ] Jake from Wisconsin
who are you you're ugly
block hit me we watch block my friend
Jake he was just joking oh really you're
ugly it's not a joke
it's just calling someone ugly so you
get blocked dude you get dealt with
that's it hands down you come at me you
get dealt with you entered the Octagon
you entered the Octagon on Twitter you
get that with how it goes some [ __ ]
idiot hit me up the other day and then
she was like she said something and I
was like uh-huh and she was like I said
some rude and I just blocked her cuz
[ __ ] it was better to not see that [ __ ]
I got a [ __ ] trigger finger block
finger bro you say some shitty put a
tech you know why does every rapper go
but it's so dumb every [ __ ] rapper is
gonna do that now they don't even do it
with it when they're talking about guns
anymore they're just like [ __ ] is going
on it's so and let's like it'd be like
if every comedian was like had a [ __ ]
thing that was like I mean come on and
they just did that every time they did
it joking I mean come on [ __ ] rap is
so shitty now you know even the good
guys it's like oh would they really be
that good when [ __ ] Tupac was around
I got that song stuck in my head well
imma [ __ ] next Kyle why my [ __ ]
next Kyle I'm glad to [ __ ] my ex car why
my ex County why's my ex Collin and he
keeps going well I'm a [ __ ] next
County and then you're like okay this is
the chorus wasn't [ __ ] next gonna well
have my [ __ ] next Kyle and then it
stand that it starts any ties well my ex
Conan oh I'd have [ __ ] ex County
waiting for the next card whatta [ __ ]
hey man
pick up the
imagine you're with imagine you're with
them and the ex keeps calling and you're
like and he's like any and he keeps
asking you my [ __ ] my ex calling uh
again why is my ex calling man was max :
hey man
ask her who she's calling hit accept
ask her hey ex by your comment well I'm
a [ __ ] that's how the song should be
well I'm a [ __ ] next count well I'm a
[ __ ] next corner woman [ __ ] next
corner
hey hey vaya con er dude Senoia also his
name six lakh that do I give a [ __ ]
that it's that he wants to pronounce it
black no well you know why you don't
pronounce a black cuz it's six lakh dude
do you like that six lakh song what's it
called well you know what it's called
you know why says it seventy five times
in the song six lakh that's not a B
that's a six therefore six lakh I mean
hey dude change the C and my name to a
seven my name is seven Chris [ __ ] hey
dude
my but still call me Chris all but
there's a seven and then in HR is oh
cool my name is seven RIS so dumb
and my ex keeps calling me I won't pick
up I don't want you to answer me why is
my ex calling a tres
what's it say yeah I mean it's weird our
hip-hop will just talk over and over and
over and over again the same [ __ ]
repeated thing sit like that if you're
choosing a ride-sharing company to drive
for go with the company that treats you
better lift only lift offers in-app
tipping when you drive for a lift you
keep a 100 percent of the tips drivers
have been paid over 150 million dollars
in tips since the feature was introduced
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost
instantly instead of waiting for weeks
150 million Jesus lyft has even taken
the guesswork out of pickups the new amp
device uses color coding to help
passengers find their drivers actually
saw that the other day it's very easy
you guy sets it to green and then you're
like oh it's that guy if you're getting
out of the club late at night and
there's 45 drivers my guys green that's
mine
you can earn hundreds of dollars a week
plus tips you want to make more money
drive more it's never been easier to
give yourself a raise it's a simple
formula happy drivers means happy
passengers and maybe that's why 9 out of
10 lift rides get a perfect five-star
rating so join the ride-sharing company
that believes in treating these people
better go to lifts calm / Congrats today
and you can get a $500 new driver bonus
that's lift calm / Congrats lift calm /
Congrats limited time only terms apply
you guys heard about five four five four
Club understands that your time is
extremely valuable and you shouldn't
waste it at the mall or wandering around
in stores I don't know why people still
shop anyway all you got to do is go
online
they've been deleting these people five
four have been the leading menswear
brand for over 15 years and you can
trust them with your wardrobe I do I
wear some other stuff and it's actually
very cool I got one shirt that is killer
that I wear all the time makes me look
actually buffer than I am
but each month they send you a curate a
box of two to three items that are
hand-picked to match the current season
and your style they've been helping men
with the fashion for over 15 years and
shipped over 100,000 men every month
they know what they're doing so if you
that's okay five for club will help you
build your wardrobe one month at a time
because when you look good you feel good
and then you can get like chicks and
stuff you know if you feel good the
chicks see it and they feel it and then
you're getting chicks
well because of five four you get $120
worth clothes for just $60 a month you
can pause or cancel anytime no
commitments and as five for club member
you also really save up to fifty percent
off items in their online shop and XS
and a can access to exclusive Members
Only items free shipping and sighs
exchanges go to five four comm go to
five four Club calm right now and enter
promo code Congrats and they'll give you
50% off your first month's package plus
a free pair of sunglasses that's fifty
percent off your first package at five
for club spelled fi ve fo you are
club.com promo code Congrats five for
club.com promo code Congrats well guys
it's time for the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post to the wheel and this is
the foreign Edition it's gonna be the
esse foreign Edition all right now a lot
of times we're like we do we hit the O's
or you know we got issues some good
dunks but this one is a guy writing in
America in American in English he is not
English obviously his name is Hans and
if anybody's name is Hans and they're
from America you know has that ever
happened I'm not giving you his handle
but it's a picture of Yellowstone I
suppose National Park and it looks
beautiful there's like a Creek in the
middle mountains are covering it some
trees basically it's a place I never
want to [ __ ] be because there's no
Starbucks there do you want me to go
somewhere to put a Starbucks on it like
Yellowstone oh really
is it disgraceful put a [ __ ]
Starbucks on it I'll go
put anything put a pizza coffee I don't
give a [ __ ] put a Seattle's best on it
you don't have a coffee shop not gone so
this is what the guy says under the
caption and this is keep in mind how is
safar in this is he writes strong as a
river in the rocks okay well I mean
first of all that's not that strong
because if the river was that strong it
will be moving the rocks but it doesn't
matter ESIF are strong as a river in the
rocks is already the beginnings of an a
safari I mean that's so first of all
it's super emotional you know when
foreign people talk they get way more
emotional you know in another language
to be like exactly this strong as a
river in the rocks ferrule as a horse in
the Prairie free and this is how he
wraps it up free as a bird in the sky
that would be a man
strong as a river in the rocks feral as
a horse in the Prairie free is a bird in
the sky that would be a men now that's
so foreign okay this is my favorite part
but this is these are the these are this
is okay
hashtag Yellowstone hashtag Yellowstone
River has tagged Wyoming hashtag
wilderness hashtag River hashtag nature
and this is the most foreign hashtag
that you've ever read in your life
hashtag Nature Park oh my god you know
yeah we going to the Nature Park yeah
hashtag Nature Park you know high
performance coach is a guy that is on an
on an Instagram high performance coach
left a comment of the a okay hand
nothing could get more far than that
high performance coach left in a okay
[ __ ] hand comment wait a minute
to live is to change and to be perfect
is to have changed often
I mean that would be a men free is a
what strong is river in the rocks feral
is a horse in the Prairie free as a bird
in the sky that would be a men really
[ __ ] it up with that last word
completely made it mean nothing it also
wouldn't be a man either so what did he
mean [ __ ] I love when people try to
speak not their language um because it's
very funny I'm sure we sound like idiots
when we try to speak you know a
different one but a holy [ __ ] that would
be a men yeah all right I'm gonna check
these hashtags
congratulations pod mm-hmm man everybody
hits gaming the system now because that
one [ __ ] [ __ ] said that
Christopher s at Stu's 1990 uh nope
change it Stu's 1990 you know what do
you think of guys who keep unlit cigars
in their mouth I mean that's cool are
you in the a team that's [ __ ] really
stupid I mean do guys for real do that
like really I mean I know they do but
like run into a bus that's driving come
on
dude [ __ ] if you did that if you do
that be in the a team be [ __ ] George
Peppard is that his name I don't know
the guy in the 18 with the white jacket
I heard that guy was the biggest
[ __ ] of all time to like such a
dick
yeah that's don't ever don't do do the
whole thing always I mean look at him go
look up Google George Peppard just
smiling with it like as if having an
unlit cigar isn't bad enough smiling
with it in it while it's in his mouth
like is there a bigger [ __ ] you to every
single person you're around than having
an unlit cigar
in your mouth smiling while holding a
gun and that was what he did that was
his part and apparently he was the
biggest [ __ ]
in all of Hollywood and naturally
because of I had to be his idea I mean
just always with a [ __ ] cigar in his
mouth
smiling unlit but he probably I think he
did light it sometimes but still don't
just have it on standby in your [ __ ]
mouth in case you need to smoke it just
put it in a [ __ ] in your car you know
what I mean
Andres or Andre I guess vivanco oh this
guy's all mixed up Andre vivanco and
then in what do you call those
parentheses avez a ves hey man just pick
a name and go with it you don't need to
have parentheses in your [ __ ] to
around at drehs vivanco Oh thoughts on
bumper stickers when would be acceptable
to use them now here's the deal
never next question dude what do you
have a baby on board by who'd you vote
for Trump [ __ ] Hillary by don't care
just vote for them yeah yeah it's not
it's not cool to do that a lot of you
guys post some pictures of this freakish
pic t-shirts in the congratulations here
the blue on the congratulations shirt is
awesome I mean this guy this is actually
funny Josh boss josh boss at josh boss
thoughts on watching porn and coming
during the position change that's pretty
funny dude cuz it's weird like when guys
are listening or watching porn and they
are about to you know finish they want
to finish at a good part you know which
is stupid because who cares they want to
like be visually stimulated while they
do it but when the camera angle changes
and
you finish I guess is what he's saying
when you're like ah man it's a bit of a
letdown I know I don't really watch that
much I don't really watch how much porn
to be honest okay this is a great
question and this guy probably doesn't
even know it but Gabe etemon at Gabe
etemon do you ever wish you were more
famous or do you like the amount of fans
fame you have okay this is actually a
real thing here I think I'm at the level
of Fame that's the most annoying because
I'm not obviously Brad Pitt I'm not that
famous
but the people who know me want to
convince me that they know me and that
they like me better than other people
who might know me and it's because I'm
not the most famous guy in the world and
that is very annoying because if you
like me and you come up and tell me you
like me I believe you you don't have to
say no no for real though you don't
understand
me and my friends and this and that and
then we did this and that and then that
oh yeah thank you but but dude I mean
and then and they start talking about
different things that I've done to prove
to me and I understand it's all nice and
all that [ __ ] but look yeah I'd
understand after a show at The Comedy
Store when I'm on the patio or something
like that you know 15 people do that
that's an hour and a half and I'm you
know maybe I'm hanging out with somebody
I'm a work person or like a you know a
the guy or something and it's you know
that that's so yeah I I would like to be
mmm the more famous because if that were
the case then you know people like Jamie
Foxx Justin Bieber they just shut that
[ __ ] down you can't even be there you
say hey man can I goo thanks yeah bye I
gotta go or otherwise you know a mob is
gonna come if I do that I look like a
piece of [ __ ] hey man no no if I say
they are man I can't do the picks can't
do it and then nobody comes up for the
next 25 minutes feel like that was
pretty
pompous does anybody else want to know
okay alright I guess I will take the
picture with you
this guy Raul Velasco at alejandro photo
7 hey man what's your name alejandro
Raul
asking about the Phelps not racing
against the real great white shark hey
man that whole [ __ ] thing was
absolutely DS s and what I mean by that
is dumb as [ __ ] okay dude he wasn't
gonna race a [ __ ] great white shark
and you knew that if you didn't know
that dude have you tuned in to watch
that a CUDA for real come on man you
knew he wasn't gonna race a [ __ ]
great white and if he did you knew that
there was gonna be a huge stone wall in
between them if you tuned into that e.e
CUDA come on man
oh yeah you also don't tune into that
cuz he's gonna lose you know why cuz a
great white shark swims up to 50 miles
an hour or no I'm sorry
25 I think it is or 30 yeah I think it's
30 I think a mako can swim up to 50 25 I
was right a human the fastest human can
swim a little bit over five miles per
hour okay so he's gonna lose a CUDA if
you just tuned in to watch it all right
that's the fastest guy and you know
Michael Phelps is probably one of the
fastest guys so fine five miles per hour
versus twenty five miles per hour
not gonna make it don't shoot it cuz
it's dumb everyone who watched therefore
was a e-e-e CUDA I mean dude come on cam
yeah don't do don't do it did you watch
it
step out step out a second did you watch
that step out of the TV room just really
quick get gunk um
yeah man let's look at some other ones
these are some good ones actually this
week thoughts on fantasy football by
Daniel Clark you know what I think about
fantasy football football is already
dorky you got guys screaming at people
and other screaming at people to run
yeah go ball get the ball in the area
and then you got guys who are pretending
to [ __ ] have a team that does that oh
there's nothing sadder fantasy football
there's nothing sadder it's said to be
in the stands and [ __ ] root for a guy
running with a ball to go to a certain
area but fantasy football pretending you
got the team there's nothing sadder um
yeah that's real [ __ ] wacky free
conch do whatever you want but just now
it's a society it's free conch do
whatever you want but just know you're
the mayor of SADS Ville would it Drake
we're with the [ __ ] what was Drake
wearing at the [ __ ] what was it the
and and it says but lassie err visuals
but that's just the photo I think that
what I see but he's wearing something
out of the material that looks like
you'd wipe your sunglasses with to make
them cleaner and why is he standing like
such a [ __ ] I like Drake but the
picture that they took he's standing
like there's a something crawling out of
his butthole and he's like trying to
like be like well I don't want people to
see it come out
hey wipe your sunglasses with that
[ __ ] shirt dude that's
that is its silk or whatever oh here's a
question Steve Butler at CUDA Master 69
very cool
why 69 what would it take for you to
camp out for something he's talking
about like in line for like a for like a
video game or something I would to camp
out for something overnight I would have
to be saving my brother's life does it
have anything to do with Xbox one no
I'll wait does it have anything to do
with ps4 no I'll wait does it have to do
with saving my mother
yeah I'll camp out
I mean just Shark Week you know what's
my favorite bad movie Connor solace at
Connor solace amazing I love all bad
movies those the only movies that like I
don't like good movies are annoying hey
what the [ __ ] was Nicolas Cage dressing
like in Kazakhstan is that is that the
like that's traditional garb there or
something I don't know but boy his face
said it all man you know how he would be
like this in movies Paul this is him in
this in this picture oh I mean what he
just looked so like alright I mean he's
getting paid for it he's gotta be
getting paid for it
he's gotta be getting paid for it
alright let's do one more and then mout
oh oh Jay's getting out how about that
man keep him in jail know why he killed
someone
hey anybody that kills someone should be
in jail yeah oh you found him not guilty
he still did it keep em in jail kee min
jail dude here's the deal man
that's the thing it's like how Denzel
won the Oscar on training day even
though he deserved it in the hurricane
movie he didn't win it because Kevin
Spacey want it give him the Oscar for
[ __ ] what it for for training day
fine
so they that's the same thing that gave
[ __ ] oj prison for robbing his sports
stuff back even though he [ __ ]
murdered two people there for key min
jail come on dude keep min jail cuz he
murdered two people
Hey
this guy this visual makes me laugh Mike
at Mike Thomas 1980 what about guys that
run backwards full-speed on a treadmill
at the gym bro if you do that get the
[ __ ] out of that gym go home run
backwards real fast home
[ __ ] [ __ ] we every somebody
running backwards at the gym we got to
all worry about this [ __ ] I'm
trying to do a bench press or some flies
and I'm now I'm stressed out that this
guy's gonna fall and break his [ __ ]
neck turn round run forward or run
backwards home copy come on dude [ __ ]
[ __ ]
if I see a dude let me tell you
something if I see a dude running
backwards on a treadmill at the gym I'm
gonna [ __ ] make sure he sees me roll
my eyes that's gonna be the hardest
workout I get the eye roll dude where
was that was that that was in the and
that was her special interest somebody
on her a headshot okay so my buddy told
me a story he saw a head shot once and
on headshots moment my producer here I
had my head shot you know it says like
special entry or special skills on the
bottom I think for mine when I had
headshots it was like I don't even know
I probably did like karate or some [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] like that martial arts you
put or something but this [ __ ] girl
had on her special skills crazy
I roll what what is that
yesterday do it and she just rolled her
eyes right she didn't ask dude crazy eye
roll dude like it's like it's a sushi
roll what about guys that [ __ ] run
backwards full-speed on the treadmill of
the gym dude that's so funny
running so fast backwards you [ __ ]
[ __ ] this guy also asked a 27 year
old at my work where as a high school
class ring daily this
a full-grown CUDA this guy might makes
me laugh
CUDA at Tsukuba this person really
people who spend their I mean really
running with the code stuff people who
spend their birthday thanking everyone
for their birthday wishes on social
media it's good alright yeah dude it is
thanks for all the birthday wishes ah
shut up dude shut up [ __ ] thank him
individually you dick go on Facebook oh
my god so blown away with all of the
birthday love oh shut up like that when
people do that I want to [ __ ] you know
what dude that's the [ __ ] thing now
if you [ __ ] see somebody on Facebook
that writes [ __ ] so blown away by all
the wonderful birthday wishes I'm
humbled with how many of you reached out
you comment under that and you go and
with a bunch of A's hey and you write
shut up like sh ad DUP not shut up shut
up
[ __ ] full grown CUDA definition of
CUDA oh my god
backwards running at the gym is the best
this guy's good two-minute there are a
lot of really good ones here this this
year this year this week
Nick serve Otis that's a weird last name
at Ensor V okay I don't like one by the
way people do that [ __ ] when they're
like [ __ ] change the last name to
[ __ ] Wilkins it's not Wilkins will
Wilkie today it's Wilkie Wilkie's here
or some [ __ ] cuz you be more of a
[ __ ] frat guy you're in a fraternity
hey if you do that and you weren't in a
fraternity congratulations
you [ __ ] were inducted into a
fraternity Hall of Fame this guy was
with
guy wrote thoughts on people who say you
can't make this up when telling a story
it's imagination you can't make this up
yay Ken yay Ken cuz it happened in real
life therefore Oh No
this guy just sent me a picture of Oh No
send me a picture of this guy Cameron
Dallas that's like that model guy that
uh and he's wearing a shirt well this'll
piss you right the [ __ ] off like
straight up he's wearing a shirt with
long sleeves one of the sleeves is cut
off and I [ __ ] you not
he's using it as one leg for his pants
do you hear what the [ __ ] I'm saying
right now and I think I have to stop the
podcast it's a good-looking kid
I guess he's got a gazillion fans but
yeah makes me want to like also is it at
Disneyland where the [ __ ] is he Oh was
yet Hogwarts [ __ ] bride hey bro stay
home dude did you want to put your
[ __ ] arm I mean what I would even say
about you know it's like
why is that she just may want to work
out why would you put your [ __ ] leg
all right I get it that I gotta actually
stop because I that [ __ ] me up
so podcast is over cuz you wore a
[ __ ] because he cut off an arm of his
[ __ ] shirt and used it as a pant leg
and walked around the [ __ ] hogwarts
ride in Disneyland
these are like a [ __ ] weirder I'm
done dude
hey guys you know what I'm done here go
to my [ __ ] shows look at Chris D'Elia
calm just two new shirts in the
merchandise [ __ ] go now
[ __ ] represent the goddamn podcast
because I tell you what if there's
[ __ ] cooties out there cutting
their arms off and use them as a pant
leg you better get the [ __ ]
congratulations shirt and stamp right in
the [ __ ] face when you see a man its
freak punch sure but you put on the
shirt you let them know Srikant but
you're watching we need these
[ __ ] this is a this more than
ever now is a cult
this is been a cult and I didn't know in
the beginning but sometimes [ __ ] goes
down and you realize what the [ __ ]
you've been doing this podcast is a
straight-up cult and you're either my
[ __ ] babies or you're Kudus you want
to be a [ __ ] CUDA and cut your arm
off and put it on your [ __ ] pant leg
you want to be a baby then you get one
of these [ __ ] shirts freak punch and
you start to be able to face you know
what dude I don't even care if you get
the shirt or not you can still be a baby
and you can still be a [ __ ] in the
cult if you don't have the outfit
understood I'm not I'm not trying to
walk the [ __ ]
you want to buy it buy it if you don't
don't [ __ ] buy it you could still be
a baby you could still be a number one
baby but dude you got to rep the [ __ ]
podcast to the fullest all right you got
to rate and review it you got it you got
to help out because you got to get this
[ __ ] global man
I'm just trying to get in a little
[ __ ] log cabin somewhere in the
middle of nowhere with a bunch of
servants nice I'll treat them nicely too
though
man on fire if you haven't watched it
with yet on Netflix go watch it man on
fire dude go check where I'm coming go
to Chris D'Elia calm I'll see you with
the shirts take pictures I want to see
in those [ __ ] things man let's grow
this cult and I'm gonna get some elders
soon so you guys you know let me know
thanks guys see you my baby
[Music]